Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
in
chapter number 73
verse verse number 19
in which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us about the verses
of this surah
and by extension the verses of the Quran
he says subhanahua
[Silence]
Such a critical verse.
What ends up happening sometimes is that
we kind of coast over
a lot of verses that are repetitive
and we might start to kind of take them
for granted almost and not give them the
amount of reflection that they are truly
due.
We look at this verse.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
indeed
these verses are a reminder
not just any reminder but if we were to
really be accurate in the translation
indeed these verses
are
an awesome reminder.
Hence, whoever wishes
to take a path to his Lord, he may do
so. Meaning using these verses and using
this Quran,
this word.
We got a look over here, huh?
[Arabic recitation]
And this is what the the scholars of
Surf referred to as
he
[Silence]
alsign.
Pay attention here closely.
There is a difference between saying
this is a reminder.
[Silence]
for
Quran. for
me.
Quran.
For
[Silence]
And so this word in Arabic, it doesn't
just mean it's a reminder.
It's an exaggeration. It means it is all
of remembrance.
It doesn't just remind. It is
remembrance.
Can you imagine the difference here
between
something that is
so for instance I gave an example of the
opening verses of Allah describes the
Quran as
it doesn't just mean that it guides the
it is guidance
it has embodied the epitome of guidance
to the point where whoever has it has
reached guidance to it. It has
epitomized guidance and whoever looks
for guidance in anywhere else has missed
all of the guidance.
Do we understand? And this is very
intentional.
Why? Because often times people want to
mix
the guidance of Allah with the guidance
of others.
Listen to what
listen to what he says about the Quran.
He says
forch.
[Silence]
Listen to the description of the
companions,
one of the greatest scholars that has
ever walked the earth, not just of our
prophet, but of all prophets. Listen to
his description of the Quran.
He says this book, the Quran, the book
of Allah,
it contains in it
the history of those who have come
before you and the prophecies of that
which is to come after you. And it
contains in it the judgment
for that which is disputed between you
all.
And it is true and final
and it is not a joking matter in the
least.
He says whoever
what any or whatever tyrant
turns away from the Quran out of
arrogance Allah will break him.
And whatever person seeks guidance in
other than the Quran, Allah will lead
him astray as a punishment.
And this is a problem that is a lot
closer to home than we might really
think.
Many of us, every Muslim, every Muslim,
we know what to say. But do our actions
really match
our statements? And do our statements
really match our convictions? Here's the
question.
Let's say we were to ask a 100 Muslims,
average everyday Muslims, and let's
speak about our place where we live in
America here. If we were to ask a 100
Muslims,
what is the guidance? What are you
guided by in your life? What will all of
them say? Every single one of them.
They'll say the Quran and Sunnah.
Correct? Everyone will say the Quran and
Sunnah.
Yet when it comes to real implementation
of this
is their followth through.
That same person
were to be presented with
an issue in their marital life or an
issue in their work life or an issue
with a friend or a companion or an issue
with their child and raising them or an
issue with their parents.
Would they really what would the first
reference be? Would their first
reference be to pick up the Quran and
look to find maybe I can find the answer
to what I'm looking for here?
Honestly, brutally honest.
[Arabic recitation]
When's the last time you heard someone
has a dispute with their wife and says,
"I'm not going to deal with this right
now. I'm going to take three four days
and read all of the Quran and try to
find
my answer in how I should deal with this
situation in the Quran or a week or two
weeks. Delay making any judgment or any
final decision before looking through
that. How many people you know that
actually do this? he's smiling over
there. How many people you know that
actually do this? Huh? What about if a
person starts to feel something?
Say a person feels anxiety. What's their
first reaction? Is it to pick up the
Quran and figure out,
you know, because the Quran is what?
Right.
Right. the mind, the heart, true
antidote for the hearts and minds. How
many people you know will pick that up?
Let's say a person is a an employer at
work. He has employees that he manages
and he wants to
be
he wants to be fair, but he wants to be
a good manager. He wants to learn how to
fill that leadership role properly and
not
you know transgress and not be
transgressed upon. What's the first book
that they will pick up to figure that
out? Huh? The se the seven habits of
highly successful people. Huh? Or the 48
laws of power. Now, we laugh, but that's
that's exactly what's happening to the
point that what is the Quran then? What
is it for? What's it for?
Well, we read it during Ramadan and we
finish it. make dua to you know we just
use the Quran for ceremonies you
know to do ceremonies
kind of many in the Jew Jewish
world they don't know they don't speak
Hebrew they don't really speak Yiddish
not all of them and they do recitation
of their book out of tradition and
ceremony right if we have a ceremony we
will recite from in the Quran otherwise
right a person is going to get married
they say I really want to be a good
husband I really want to be a good wife
what's the first book they pick up to
figure that out huh men are from Mars
and women are from Venus right that's a
real book about marriage and women and
the nature of right what about I want to
be a good father what's the first book
they pick up, huh? Rearing children in
modern society, right? Etc., etc. What
happened to the Quran? What happened to
it?
Oh, the Quran now is only for scholars.
Oh, the Quran now is only for
ceremonies,
but if I really have something
important, then I go to the
professionals.
Right? So the Quran is not a serious
book. It's a book for ceremonies
and it's a book for
you know it's a book for ceremonies
and it's a book for you know browsing
here and there and that's why you'll
find someone been Muslim 10 years 20
years 30 years 40 years never read the
whole Quran never did it just never got
around to it
just never really,
you know, and these are not just
illiterate people. These are intelligent
people. People that have gone to medical
school, people that have gone to, right,
engineering school, people who have high
levels of education, but the Quran is
the lowest one on that list.
How many of us truly truly search for
understanding in the Quran of anything
of anything
let alone the Sunnah? I mean that one is
right and so the Quran many Muslims
aren't even aware
that there's even any of these issues
talked about in the Quran. What is the
Quran? Alhamdulillah.
That's the Quran. That's it. That's all
that's in the Quran.
And then measure that with the statement
of Ali that we just heard. Listen to it
again.
Whenever form.
[Silence]
Muslim.
And so we listen now and we compare that
to the statement of Ali that we just
heard. Let us listen to it again. The
book of Allah has in it the history of
those who have come before you and the
prophecies of what is to come after you.
And it has judgment in the dispute and
that which is between you. And it is a
true and decisive criterion. And it is
not in the least a joking matter.
Whatever tyrant turns away from it out
of arrogance, Allah will break him. And
whoever looks for guidance in other than
the Quran, Allah will take him astray.
Now, does this mean
that a person cannot learn anything
outside of the Quran and Sunnah? No.
But the problem isn't that really, is
it? The problem isn't we learn the Quran
and you know
you know wisdom is the lost property of
every believer. Wherever he finds it he
takes it. Right? That's not really the
issue is it? The issue is we don't even
know what's in our book anymore.
We don't even begin with our book
anymore.
All we know is we're supposed to love
it.
All we know is we're supposed to read it
and recite it. And for this reason,
we you know, I wouldn't say a a
majority, but I will say a huge portion
of us when we teach our our children the
Quran, what is the highest level of
education we give our children with
respect to the Quran? the out of
the ordinary highest degree that someone
will impart upon his child as far as
knowledge of the Quran will be.
[Arabic recitation]
Memorize the Quran. That's it.
Memorize the Quran. We're done.
Have no idea what we're saying.
Well, I have no idea.
How many times do we read the word?
What does the word mean?
Easy question.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
what is
what is Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala says
many of us memorized This right?
What is
what is
etc etc.
Right? The problem isn't that we're not
reading the Quran. The problem is we're
not reading the Quran. Right?
We're reading it in a language that we
don't understand. That isn't necessarily
the issue. The issue is why is it that
we don't have the inclination to know
what that means? If I read it every
single day, why is it that I don't know
what it means? Why?
And so the Quran has taken a backseat.
When we speak, we say yes, the Quran and
the Sunnah, but then when we behave,
what happens? A man and woman have a
dispute. A man has a dispute with his
wife. They say, "You know what? Let's
find out who's right and who's wrong in
this." What's the first thing they will
refer to?
Counselor. No, that's Wish it was a
counselor. First thing right now, what
will they refer to? Huh?
What's the first thing? Chad GPT.
Google.
Seriously, Google. And you know how we
will stop this? You know how? I'll tell
you now.
We will stop this by by not worshiping
not worshiping
these other fields.
And second of all, we will stop this by
taking a vow starting tonight right now.
A vow, a solemn vow.
I will not refer to anything on a screen
for serious knowledge. Nothing. Tell me
how many professionals do we have here?
We have mechanics and engineers and
doctors. If I were to tell you I learned
to be a doctor. I don't have the
certification, but I learned to be a
doctor all on the internet. All on my
own. What would you think about that?
Would you let me perform perform perform
surgery on your child?
You have a malignant tumor. Let me get
it out for you. Huh? Come lay down on my
table. I read a lot of Google pages. I
watched a lot of videos and I know and I
know that the doctors, they differ on
this issue. And that's how we take our
religion, right? imagine
this. Let's say someone
were to start to have symptoms that they
fear might be cancer. They fear it might
be a serious illness.
Man, I've been watching this and I feel
something is wrong. Would they go
onto the internet,
find a page that says these symptoms
could be cancer and they could just be a
cold? And so he says, you know, it's a
difference of opinion amongst the
scholars of medicine. So I'm going to
just go ahead with go with it's a cold.
It's not it's not a tumor. It's it's not
cancer. But maybe it is can Yeah, but
maybe it's not. It's a difference of
opinion. I'll go with the easier one.
What do you think?
Would we would we do that or would we
consider that person
seriously unwell? Right?
But that's the same kind of behavior,
isn't it? Well, is this haram or is this
halal? Well, what I've read, as far as I
know, and I'm not a scholar, but what
I've read, what I've heard is that it's
a difference of opinion, right? And so,
you know, you could choose whatever
opinion you want. Some scholars say it's
okay and some say it's not okay. And
just go with that one. Is that
knowledge? Is that any kind of
knowledge? Is there any serious
knowledge on earth that is dealt with in
this way? No. But we deal with our
religion this. Why? What happened
to our jealousy? What happened to our
anger for the sake of Allah? What
happened to we will not allow anyone to
stick his fingers in our book and
religion and meddle with it? What
happened to we don't allow people who
call themselves scholars, who don't know
whether to wind their cheek or
smack their watch. We won't allow them
to come and impersonate the scholars of
Islam and meddle with our dean and
meddle with our children and meddle with
our religion and our prayer and our
misogyny. What happened to those people?
Where'd they go?
Until we find those people again,
we look around in the world. We see how
it is. But Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us
If you believe that, then you will
believe
that is it possible for me to find
guidance and true tranquility
only using the Quran and Sunnah. Nothing
else. If the answer is yes, then why are
we looking elsewhere? If the answer is
no, then that's a whole other problem
and a whole other kettle of fish. But
the problem is is that now many people
will even look down upon scholars of
Islam,
right? And say, you know, they don't
read other things, just the Quran and
just the Sunnah. What else you want them
to read?
What are what else are they supposed to
be? That's their that's what they
specialize in, isn't it? Or is their
guidance incomplete until they read
other things? Until they read the
philosophies of Greek and Rome or until
they read the the scriptures of the
Hindus and ancient Buddhists. What do
you want them to read? or until they
read the works of modern atheists or
the works of modern neoliberal
you know people that can't figure out
what's the difference between a man and
a woman. They have no idea yet. We can't
really get it down. It's it's an elusive
topic. It's we're not sure. It's we
we're not sure what's a man and what's a
woman. But they're going to tell us how
to find happiness and how to find
guidance and contentment and what's a
good person and what's a bad person.
Until the Muslims wake up and come out
of this fever dream that we're in, we
will not be able to reclaim the honor
that was once ours and belonged to our
forefathers.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Subhanahua.
[Silence]
What's up?